inter stella hatte recht also der
spielfilm so sieht ein schwarzes loch
von der seite aus die nasa hat eine
detailgetreue visualisierung eines
schwarzen loches von der seite erstellt
also aus der ebene der akkretionsscheibe
und sie zeigt gewaltig verzerrt und
verbeugt sich das ausblicks um
science-fiction er gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktivierte glocken und dann
verpasst er nicht losgeht hat sie
bekommen das war eine echte premiere und
ein historischer durchbruch das erste
bild eines schwarzen lochs das in diesem
frühjahr 2009 10 veröffentlicht wurde
zu sehen ist der schwerkraft gigant der
galaxie m87 erkennbar ist ein
kreisförmiger licht ring um den dunklen
schatten des zentralen schwarzen loches
als beobachter schaut man von oben auf
das schwarze loch und die
akkretionsscheibe herren nasa
forschungsteam ist jetzt der spannenden
frage nachgegangen wie ein schwarzes
loch aussieht wenn es von der seite aus
betrachtet wird herausgekommen ist eine
detailgetreue visualisierung die auf
einer speziellen software und
astrophysikalischen berechnung basiert
auf den ersten blick wird klar dass
solch ein schwerkraft gigant von der
seite aus ganz anders aussieht also als
beispielsweise der ringplanet saturn
eine kugel mit einem schmalen ring bei
einem schwarzen loch ist das ganz anders
der grund dafür ist seine schwerkraft
wirkung auf das licht bereiche die
normalerweise verdeckt sein müssten
werden sichtbar und sein aussehen ist
extrem verzerrt da sind im schwarzen
loch im film film intercell sehr ähnlich
kein wunder da war ja auch der
theoretische physiker und
nobelpreisträger kipp form mit im team
ja die dunkle schwarze mitte
die stellt hierbei den schatten des
schwarzen lochs da hier dringt kein
licht nach außen dass kein entrinnen für
das licht gibt das dem schwarzen loch zu
nahe gekommen ist sehr deutlich wird
also dass schwarze löcher als enorme
schwerkraft giganten alles licht
schlucken und somit selbst unsichtbar
bleiben hinter dem ereignishorizont dem
point of no return verschwindet alles
doch selbst hier hat das starke
gravitationsfeld des schwarzen lochs
seinen finger endspiel der schatten
erscheint anderthalb mal so groß wie der
ereignishorizont der schatten erscheint
sogar 2,5 mal so groß wenn das schwarze
loch rotiert die visualisierung zeigt
also sehr eindrucksvoll
enormen einfluss schwarze löcher auf das
licht in ihrer umgebung haben dadurch
verraten sich die schwerkraft giganten
dann auch überhaupt unter anderem für
die strahlung der sogenannten
akkretionsscheibe gebeugt so dass deren
licht einen kreisförmigen licht ring um
den ereignishorizont bildet bei diesen
aggressions schreiben handelt es sich um
materie schreiben sie bestehen aus gas
und rotieren um das schwarze loch herum
und zwar fast mit lichtgeschwindigkeit
doch da die ansicht von der seite aus
auf das schwarze loch erfolgt ist die
scheibe nicht als scheibe zu sehen der
grund die gravitation sorgt dafür dass
das licht des schwarzen lochs auf
gekrümmten bahnen gelenkt wird und nicht
dem normalen weg folgt das ist wirklich
ganz besonders denn die
akkretionsscheibe ist in dieser
visualisierung also nicht wie gewohnt
von der schmalseite auszusehen sondern
von unten und oben gleichzeitig wird um
das loch herum gebogen ein abbild des
rings scheint also nach unten und ein
weiteres nach oben gebogen zu sein durch
die ablenkung des lichts sieht es so aus
als sei der hintere teil der scheibe
nach oben geklappt und eben nach unten
außerdem fällt ins auge dass der linke
rand heller ist als der rechte rand der
scheibe der grund das gas auf der linken
seite bewegt sich auf den betrachter der
visualisierung zu hier ist also eine art
dopplereffekt im spiel in der physik
wird damit ja die zeitliche dehnung
beziehungsweise stauchung einer welle
beschrieben die durch veränderungen des
abstandes zwischen sender und empfänger
zustande kommen das vom gas emittierte
licht wird gebündelt auf der rechten
seite läuft das anders das glas bewegt
sich weg vom beobachter des bildes der
teil der scheibe sie dunkler aus da das
emittierte licht gestreut wird eine
helle feine licht linie umgibt den
dunklen schatten des schwarzen lochs
ganz in der mitte
hierbei handelt es sich um einen
photonen ring die gravitation ist hier
so stark dass das licht im kreis läuft
das licht hat den ereignishorizont also
mehrfach umkreist und sind somit auf
eine kreisbahn gezwungen dabei würde es
immer dünner und langgezogener bis es
dann entweichen kann
dem schwarzen loch entkommt und unsere
augen erreicht dazu der
nasa-wissenschaftler jeremy schnitt man
simulationen wie diese helfen uns dabei
zu verstehen was einstein meinte als er
sagte dass gravitation die raumzeit herz
schwarzes loch sein oder nichtsein bei
über raum tv anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren cooler kanal mit extrem
fundiertem wissen bis dann bleibt dran